what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight death prediction video I know a
lot of you have been asking me to make
this video so I figured I would give
some my early predictions about which
characters I think will die in the final
season before any row spoilers or photos
come out let me know which characters
you think will die down in the comment
section and we can see who gets the most
right after season 8 ends this video
will only be part one of my list of
characters that I think will die and I
will release a part 2 video with more
characters as soon as possible alright
now let's get started with the
predictions my first prediction is sir
Jaime [ __ ] Lannister and I know
plenty of people who hate this character
but I have to be honest with you Jaime
Lannister has grown on me ever since
season 3 this was a man I hated with the
passion during season 1 and 2 but I have
grown to love this character although he
still has some issues with him the
reason why I say this is because I do
not want Jamie to die I would like to
see him live some sort of normal life
after it's all said and done but I just
don't see this character surviving the
great war he has pretty much lost all of
his ability to defend himself
in fact he should have died a few times
already but he has been lucky enough to
stick around ever since he lost his hand
he has lost his legendary sword fighting
skills and now he is heading north in a
place where not too many people like him
I do think Jaime will be accepted into
Winterfell when they will allow him to
fight with them but I don't see anyone
other than maybe Brienne being willing
to stick their neck out to save Jaime if
he gets into some trouble in the
battlefield I'm not necessarily saying
anybody's gonna let him die because
they're gonna need his help no matter
what but let's just say I don't see
anybody willing to take a bullet for him
other than Brienne the knight King and
his army are making their way south and
before you know it the north is going to
be completely under attack and everyone
in John and Danny's camp will eventually
be surrounded by whites and White
Walkers in my opinion I don't see Jaime
making it out of this alive he may still
find an opportunity to kill Cersei but I
think Jaime will die in the Great War
and he will die in the arms of the woman
he loves just like he said he wanted but
the woman that he loves is not going to
be Cersei which is who he meant at the
time when he said that but he will
actually die in the arms of Brienne
that's how I think Jamie's story's going
to
and but and this is a big but I think
Jamie will die by actually sacrificing
himself for one of the Starks possibly
bran Stark but if it's not a stark whose
life he saves then I think it could be
brands I see Jamie dyin in one of the
most honorable ways possible which is
sacrificing himself so others can live I
don't think this is something someone
could really imagine Jamie doing back
when he was a cocky handsome man of the
Kingsguard but since this story began
with Jamie pushing bran out of the
window I think his story will end by
saving one of the Starks also after
Jamie dies I believe Brienne or someone
else will make sure Jamie's pages and
the white book get filled with some of
the deeds that he has done and will do
in the future after the Great War is
over someone will make sure that it is
written in history books that Jamie
didn't murder the Mad King for no reason
but he did it to save the city and they
will make sure that it is known that he
sacrificed himself during the long night
the next character that I believe will
die is grey worm I actually thought grey
worm would die in season seven because
they kept typing up his relationship
what Masson day and all the promos and
trailers so I assumed they would kill
one of these characters once they got
everybody invested in their relationship
but of course both of these characters
were pretty much put on the sidelines
midway through the season I also think
grey worm will die in the north fighting
the army of the dead grey worm has
always felt sort of like an expendable
character to me but even more so in the
last season grey worm has never fought
in the north before he has never fought
in the freezing temperatures with the
ground covered in snow and I don't think
the unsullied or Dothraki are going to
fare very well in the northern terrain I
do think my Sande will survive the
entire series but I think she's going to
do it without grey worm they will
probably show these two characters
connect one more time right before he
goes into battle and then they will tear
another relationship apart by killing
one of them and I think that person will
be great worm I also think the entire
Nights Watch will cease to exist - and I
made a video specifically about this
before but I will briefly go over my
thoughts on this again basically we're
gonna lose at least half of the
remaining characters that are left in
this series and some of the first people
to go will be the type of characters
that will no longer be needed in the
final episode or I should say during the
rebuilding
Faye's the dream of spring phase I think
the night King and his minions will be
stopped for good this time they will be
completely defeated and they're not
gonna go to sleep under the ice again
for thousands of years they will be
extinct which means there will no longer
be a need for the Nights Watch the men
of the Nights Watch were meant to
protect the realm from everything that
lies beyond the wall but after the great
war is over there will be nothing left
to protect everyone from north of the
wall the wildlings and other tribes are
already either south of the wall or dead
and once the night king and his army are
dead then there will be nothing north of
the wall that anyone will really have to
worry about anymore they technically
wouldn't even need to rebuild the wall
because I don't think the others are
gonna be pushed back up north this time
like I said I think they're gonna be
going for good the wall and the Nights
Watch will no longer serve its purpose
and from now on they will have to throw
their criminals in a jail cell no more
running to the wall and joining the
black I think this will also be a part
of the new Westeros too things are not
going to be done exactly the same as
they were before and getting rid of the
Nights Watch will be one of those things
no more barriers keeping people out of
the Seven Kingdoms Jon Snow has already
made sure that and I think this will
continue after the Great War next on my
list is another one of my favorite role
players good old beric Dondarrion and
let's be honest here barrack has been
living on borrowed time for multiple
seasons now this man should have died
six times already
in fact he's already dead in the books
dead for good too he sacrificed himself
to bring lady Catelyn back to life as
Lady Stoneheart and obviously they never
did this in his show but Barrack will
die at some point and I just hope they
let him go out in style hopefully they
will allow him to use his ability from
the books and give someone the last kiss
don't just kill barrack off like he's
some run-of-the-mill character give it
some finesse if it were up to me I would
have him die by giving the last kiss to
another major character I think that
would be a cool way to send him off and
it could be another nod to the books but
once again this is just my opinion that
is something I would like to see happen
if they decide to bring him back into
the story again and then ultimately end
his story
speaking of beric Dondarrion the next
character on my list is tormund
Giantsbane and it actually hurts me to
say this because torment is in my top
five favorite characters of all time
I've loved this character
ever since he was introduced even when
he was technically the bad guy I would
hate to see tormund die and they damn
near broke my heart in the finale when
the wall came crashing down at Eastwatch
it didn't look good for barrack and
torment but I'm hoping they can avoid
being killed as the dead marched through
the wall I need to see torment in the
Great War kicking some ass but I'm
afraid he's gonna die in the end even
the showrunners Dayne and Dave said
either torment or Brienne will die and
obviously they could be trying to
mislead people but basically what
happened was somebody asked them about
torment and burying and hooking up and
they said one of them must die in the
end they will not live happily ever
after together and I think if one of
them is to die then it would be torment
Brienne is arguably one of the best
fighters left on the show and she
definitely knows how to defend herself
and she has a Valyrian steel sword so
she could defend herself against the
White Walkers as well
I think Brienne will survive the entire
series but she will lose both of the men
that are in her life because Jaime in
torment will die torment was lucky
enough to survive the mission beyond the
wall and he was lucky to survive the
wall coming down but I think the third
time will be the charm
three strikes and torment is out the
next character that I think will die is
Sir Gregor Clegane the motherfunking
mountain I have no way to put this
philosophically or poetically this
[ __ ] just needs to die I don't care
if he dies during cleganebowl or if he
slips on a banana peel someone must take
this man down there is no way they can
let him survive this entire series this
freakshow has been wreaking havoc since
the first season and in my opinion he
will see his Judgment Day
it's not how it ends for you brother you
know who's coming for you you've always
known
you can't have the hound deliver a
bone-chilling line like that to the
mountain and not give us some kind of a
payoff he must pay for what he did to
another one of my favorite characters
Oberyn Martell I am still keeping my
fingers crossed for cleganebowl but if I
had a second choice it would be Arya
Stark
she still has him on her list and she
hates the mountain and I would love to
see her take this big man down if the
Hound can't do it on his own
let me add one more character to this
list for the part 1 video then I will
get out of here
and since I am already talking about the
mountain who is in King's Landing let me
just slide right on over to Cersei
[ __ ] Lannister the Wicked Witch of
Westeros I think I can speak for 90% of
the fan base when I say we can't wait to
see this evil twisted brother loving
[ __ ] drop dead sir seize time is up
she must die and once again I really
don't care who does the deed but if they
want to make it extremely satisfying
then she needs to be killed by Jaime or
Tyrion or dare I even say Sansa now I
know Cersei is on arias list and Arya
really wants to kill her but I think it
would be more satisfying if Songza was
able to kill her instead of Arya songs I
had to put up with Circe's evilness way
more than Arya ever did and I would be
extremely satisfied if Songza was able
to cast her down somehow but I think
Jaime or Oriya is actually more likely
to deliver the fatal blow but there is a
strong chance that Cersei will live
until the very last episode considering
all of her enemies are now in the north
and they are about to be at war in the
north since the night king is already
south of the wall Jon and Danny are
gonna have to focus on him immediately
which allow Cersei to continue living
unless that is of course someone decides
to take a quick trip to King's Landing
and finish her off
even if Jon and Danny's forces are
completely decimated by the night king I
still believe they will have enough left
over to take care of Cersei into whoever
she may have fighting for her in the end
then someone's gonna need to slip behind
enemy lines and most likely choke the
life from her and end her reign for good
comment down below and let me know what
you think of my list do you agree with
any of them or do you disagree and think
someone on my list will survive at all
let me know because I am anxious to get
some feedback on this one and like I
said this is only part 1 there will be a
- - this video soon and I will list all
of the other big remaining characters I
have left thanks for stopping by
everybody and watching today's video I
appreciate that as always and I must
thank all of my patreon supporters as
well and a big thanks to all of my new
patreon supporters that I got this week
it truly means a lot to me I hope you
all have a great day and I will see you
in the next one bye
[Music]